les passionnés des rallyes automobiles
la connaissent car depuis quelques
années à des partages de cet amour pour
la voiture et la mécanique tout
particulièrement elle dirige avec une
main de fer son propre garage qu'il
s'agisse de gestion d'organisation de
tôlerie ou de mécanique secteurs
d'activité caïds et nous confirme
accessible aujourd'hui aux femmes
ça fait sept ans que je suis wind ça
fait sept ans que je suis là n'est gagné
on est à 3 si je me trompe en est à
trois mois pas beaucoup non je crois
qu'il y en a une seule port et une à
saint pierre d'après ce que j'avais fait
une petite recherche juste par curiosité
j'avais demandé à la chambre des métiers
je crois qu'on est à trois et ils
apprécient beaucoup je lui ai appris
avec mon compliments avec le chat qui
c'était la passion quoi vous croyez moi
je n'ai pas du tout fait ça comme métier
j'ai appris pour faire de la
comptabilité j'ai été hôtesse d'accueil
à l'aéroport et on a ouvert après le
garage au corps
donc on a tout fait comme ça je mets au
départ c'était uniquement peut-être même
embarquer au départ c'était que vie et
moi donc j'ai tellement vécu voilà
maintenant maintenant jeux géants jeux
manager et tous ensemble de façon à ce
qu'ils aient pu libérer au niveau de
tout ce qui est préparation donc je
donne un coup de main tout ce qui est
commandes de pièces tout ce qui est
client et le manoeuvre en porte
puis bon ce qui est bien c'est qu'on
alloue cia leur relation a cédé peu tôt
le matin wall cas c'est ensemble que ce
sens parce que c'est parce que je suis
patron que y'a patrons et employés non
c'est toute la bande c'est une équipe on
est une équipe soudée qu'on s'a portant
oui on le pense de l'ambiance est
meilleure donc on travaille dans le com
- travaillent dans des très bonnes
conditions pour ça
vous avez combien de personnes que
travailler ses rivaux j'arrache on est
marié à chaque clignement spatiale
en est à cinq sa
5,5 et puis après il ya les copains qu
il donne un coup de main pour le rallye
super point là vous habitez sur place
comme un maquereau au cros savoir pacha
annoncée puis c'est l'inconvénient que
la boj bien sûr oui parce que là bas
c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas d'oreille un
don quand
on ouvrait m'en tiens voilà on tient
jamais compte de du réveil que ce soit
on le mange et demi dit que ce sens pour
le repas du sancy par l'alcool la
chica dise ce que vous voulez des
projets danse mais cela ce que j'avais
envie de continuer ah oui oui drôle et
ça bah oui ça me plaît ça me plaît
d'autant plus lorsque c'est suis une
femme mais voila voila je me déciderai
non mais je crois ce qu'elle c'est vrai
que je me rappellerai toujours quand je
cite allé m'inscrire la chambre des
métiers
je suis allé pendant trois jours et
pendant les trois hommes à poser
exactement la même question vous êtes
venu pourquoi j'ai dit c'est pour ouvrir
un garage pardon ou de sétif c'est venu
ouvrir un garage ou bien d'accord
c'était si bon que ça ça j'ai ressenti
ça c'est quand à chacun de poser la
question pour demander à ce qu'ils
entendent bien
j'utilise bien le bon terme et tout quoi
oui mais mine de rien c'est que les
femmes non admis c'est pas qu'on
critique sans pareil mais je veux dire
que nous livrent aux gestions et tout ça
je vais pour faire tourner l'entreprise
sur la gestion il faut l'administratif
ce qu'il y avait derrière sinon ça pique
de la tête c'est ce que je disais à la
chambre des métiers il suffit pas d'avs
de savoir de connaître mais il faut
qu'une bonne gestion pour une entreprise
tiens
voilà ça n'arrive pas à gérer à être là
comme avec les clients bon ben tu es
diaconu au niveau des clients d pas
insisté pareil quand je leur disais
comment c'était un tel choc dit vous
êtes sûr je l'écouté c'est simple on va
les voir mais calme deux ans et quand je
présentais un homme comme l'âme 10 rb
oui effectivement avez raison il ya la
fameuse partir de 180 que ce soit les
fournisseurs c'est moi qui m'en occupe
bon il avait du mal au départ a tout
fait avant c'était toujours recherche
patron même jusqu'à maintenant ça arrive
encore à caen
1 combien sont arrivés dimanche je
cherche patron s'est passé - dias fusée
mois au niveau des excuses j'en ai
encore sur ce point là que c'est au
téléphone quand on appelle handball juré
par le patron je vais je vais c'est la
patronne on n'a pas l'habitude non non
non franchement on y z'ont pas du tout
l'habitude que ce soit une femme qui
sont
moi j'aime bien guinée bon bah oui ça
fait 7 passes gérer ça fait du bien mais
c'est sûr que le travail va être bien
fait c'est à dire que bon on sait que je
donne mes objectifs je dis pas qu'il ya
que le baiia le rallye c'est ça qu'il
faut bosser plus ils sont là en
conséquence ils sont payés en
conséquence donc j'attends quelque chose
et lorsque ben on est retombé cora cas
le rallye c'est pas que pour moi c'est
pour eux aussi ils ont la fierté de dire
qu'il travaille sinon donc reparti le
fasse bien automne on sera content mais
bon ma maman matelot 10 pour commander
faut savoir faire donc c'est pour ça que
j'ai appris la mécanique pour pouvoir
commander
vous êtes sur tous les rallyes donc tout
même quand j'étais enceinte
là ça c'est la passion oui bon j'étais
pas en assistance rapide j'étais en
assistant 6 parce que bon niveau voiture
s'était pas c'était pas le temps mais
j'ai fait le toto j'ai fait en
assistance rapide malgré que j'attendais
mon garçon génial ou lukaku d'intention
de sa voiture et le petit ou à saint
amand du temps d'isolement j'ai déjà ils
arrivent ils à il connaît tout des
marques de voitures par coeur ils
arrivent déjà démonté verrous il ay
connais quelques pièces déjà il a que
trois ans mais on connaît déjà pas mal
de dents je pense que l'on a vite assuré
ce soir là
dans des pâtures comme s'agit de
voitures de rallye par exemple parce que
vous faites exactement en préparant par
mécaniques ont fait en un niveau
mécanique bon on prépare pas tout dépend
bien sûr de quelle catégorie de voiture
dans laquelle elle court qui peut être
groupe a au groupe nc n'est pas les
mêmes innovation donc c'est pas les
mêmes travail qui a fait ça nous arrive
de faire de l'aide d'une voiture
d'origine et la montée en rallye on
prend une voiture de tous les jours on a
des habits on melanson gratte la caisse
et on prépare tout mais peu partout il
ya préparé tout c'est à dire qu'on
prépare de laquelle son soudan prépare
le moteur on prépare au niveau des
hameaux qui ont préféré commander
amortisseurs ont fait les réglages et
train avant arrière et on fait les
réglages de suspensions mais tout dépend
de ce que les pilotes demandé de ce que
lui il ressent dans la voiture le
réglage se fait par rapport aux pilotes
à ce que vous ça vous arrive d'essayer
une voiture ali ben oui on sait c'est
obligé c'est parce que j'évolue au
volant de temps en temps ce plaisir à
mon fils je l'aimé parce qu'il aime ça
mais sinon ça
j'ai sec le pilote pour voir ensemble et
puis me dis tout de suite les
ressent pour qu'on puisse travailler si
ça qu'on fait les et sert à chaque
rallye
parce que vous trouvez que les fans
maintenant s'intéressent plus à la
mécanique parce que bon à l'époque on
disait qu'ils n'arrivent même pas à
changer une roue de voiture au travail
et sa mosquée as ça c'est la bonne
esquisse un mégot maintenant on peut
leur montrer un et c'est vrai que bon ma
maman est là peu vexé de ne pas me voir
tous les jours maquiller et bien
habillées mais
celle en vie si c'est la passion elle
mène c'est de dire que bon je suis une
femme et je fais quelque chose dans tout
et puis bon c'est venu vraiment parce
que bon
nous on a fait vraiment pas encore ali
c'est à dire comment on sait qu'une
passion on aime bien avoir les aime bien
toucher un petit peu a tous évolué
tester voir si ce qu'on pense dans la
tête ça va marcher vraiment ça c'est
plus mon mari qui le fait franchement
mais bon je lui donne un coup de main là
dessus mais c'est vraiment la passion
c'est un métier d'avenir
oui il faut évoluer avec son temps c'est
à dire que nous on s'est pas arrêtée
qu'à la mécanique avec toi comme ça on
est passé à la programmation boîtier on
a beaucoup on s'est beaucoup diversifié
c'est que maintenant nous on fait la
pause des boîtiers on règle les voitures
sur la route avec l'ordinateur on joue
avec l'électronique aussi mais parce que
vous pensez vraiment dur à lui
actuellement ça a bien changé fabien
chansons d'amour heureux que ce soit au
niveau de l'ambiance et tout ça
maintenant se tire tout droit pourquoi
se cacher avant c'était bon on se trouve
et se prêter une clé sans problème ça
rigolait bien mais maintenant c'est
vraiment en compétition mais que ce soit
sur la route serait spécial que ce soit
dans les équipes quoi
dommage c'est demain si cette
ambiance-là qui a plus mais bon comme la
passion est là on va s'aimer mais bon
y'a d'autres ça tombe toujours impatient
mais à d'autres reprises plus pris ça
pour un métier ce que je trouve dommage
quoi comme ça reste à loisir c'est pas
c'est pas plus cher
il ya deux khemaïes travail plage on
aime l'être dans les spéciales être
suffi
on peut par la voiture on emmène ça nous
arrive de faire des petites faveurs
d'emmener la voiture pour le pilote tout
autant ça m'arrive de la vie de la
voiture avant de prendre des parts
pourquoi ces marches était de dire que
la voiture entre les profs on est tout
un ensemble des kippas fait rire
l'assistance on stresse ensemble on
rigole bien on s'en met tous donc ça on
voit pas le à passer des gens mais
deuxièmement c'est que quand on emmène
le pilote on emmène aux ici on est là on
n'est pas dans les rallyes on est là que
ce soit après remise des prix on est là
bas tout ça ça fait qu'il se sent bien
bien encadré et ça le permis d'avancer
à dehors ce sont cités des copains qui
sont devenus qui sont venus travail
qu'on a fait travailler parce que bon
mon départ n'était que deux il y avait
que lui et moi qui ai la mesure où on a
pris des copains qui est au chômage de
façon si tu peux on l'apprend quelque
chose savaient une deuxième chose dans
mon garage qui est assez marrant c'est
que mon corps plus bakassi ap bp de quel
niveau c'est à dire qu'il ya le plus
haut niveau mécanique mais ott n'ont pas
fait une mécanique
ces emprunts serait pas avec mon
concubin
c'est à dire que j'aime fixe débuts dans
la vie mais bon tout se lit auto du
garage ça se passe mais je veux dire
c'est à dire que bon je me mets des
petits projets dans la tête et puis
avance à petits pas mais soucieux
d'avancer
c'est ça c'est marie si c'est devant ce
pur n'est devenu après cette annonce
d'année ses devoirs c'est à dire qu'on
aurait fait on fait pas mal de photos
quand on fait des petites routes entre
amis et il ya quinze jours de cela
j'avais été animateur je vais mettre un
petit peu d'ordre là-dedans il piste et
pour montrer à mon fils faille était
bébé puis retrouvez les photos c'est de
voir ce qu'était le garage avant dans
les conditions dans lesquelles on
travaillait et de vendre maintenant et
c'est sûr que vont il ya des amis qu'on
voit pas tout le temps ou six noms qui
viennent que pour les vacances qui
habite en métropole quand ils arrivent
ils à chaque fois il dit nev ça évolue
ça avance c'est sûr que ça n'apporte pas
que des jo à tout le monde il ya c'est
comme ça c'est un truc est dommage ici
ne conçoit pas partout pareil quand on
voit quelqu'un avance
il ya la jalousie mais bon ces seuils de
phase i est un moteur souffre un oui
ce que j'ai envie de faire passer ce
taux aux femmes c'est de dire que bon
j'ai déjà vu que maintenant il ya des
femmes qui sont chauffeurs de bus non
qu'on voit maintenant que celle du
langage que dans tout métier on peut y
être tout est question de volonté c'est
tout après on même si grande passion
derrière c'est sûr que ça marche la
preuve